good day everybody welcome back to css3
in 30 days today is day number 28 and
instead of coding in this lesson we're
going to spend a little bit of time
talking about optimizing your css3
good clean code is always a great idea
here are some hot tips on optimizing
your css3
first of all code better you got to do
the work right the first time
don't rely on optimization tools to make
you a good css3 coder as I always like
to say crap in crap out that simply
means if you are putting something
terrible into the machine something
terrible will come out no matter how
much you prettify or optimize or
compress the darn thing if you're doing
a bad job in it's going to be a bad job
coming out so remember crap in crap out
when coding your CSS use shallow
selectors instead of really long and
messy redundant selectors and that
simply means if you can select simply
the ID of awesome don't select div
paragraph tag span em ID of awesome just
simply using the ID of awesome is good
enough that in and of itself is smart
css3 coding utilize good code
organization so instead of when you have
an idea for a style just throwing it at
the bottom of your CSS style sheet find
out where a good place for that piece of
code is and a nice little tip is put a
table of contents in a comment up at the
very top of your style sheet if you have
a really big and heavy CSS style sheet
have some organization and have a way
that you in the future can revisit your
code or if you're handing off the
project to somebody else they can see
what the heck you were doing use
shorthand where possible so instead of
margin top 20 pixels margin rank 20
pixels margin bottom 20 pixels margin
left 20 pixels just say margin 20 pixels
and treat your CSS 3 like it is art it's
not just letters in a code editor
it's your art it's your craft it's what
makes the web run or at least it's what
makes the web look good
so treat
like it is art because arguably it is
hot tip number to validate your code
sometimes the smallest error in your
code can cause the biggest headache so
be smart and use one of those free and
awesome tools out there like this one
just CSS portal com CSS - optimize all
you got to do is Google CSS optimizer or
optimize your CSS there's a lot of tools
out there this is one that I found and
I'll just show you real quick how it
works so I have some CSS here queued up
I'm just gonna hit paste relatively
short CSS file but what I'm gonna do is
I'm going to optimize it by compressing
it and choosing different settings here
in the tool so standard Otzi let's make
it let's start here highest no read
readability smallest size if you have a
production-ready stylesheet that you
want to have ready to go then you can
have it at its highest compression
because you don't need to be able to
read it and modify it that's for
developers only when you want to be able
to see all your code easily see the
organization the table of contents the
comments everything like that
production-ready live sites you don't
really need to have it be that readable
so I'm gonna say highest this option
preserves CSS you can save the comments
hacks and so on and so forth by default
they have it turned off I would keep it
off for now if you're having it be
highly compressed you can sort the
selectors that says use this with
caution that may change the behavior of
your CSS code because it's not a perfect
tool sorting properties you can even
sort the properties by I don't know what
method they're sorting them but you can
test it out and see what it does or you
can leave it off
you can also regroup selectors optimize
shorthands all of these sorts of things
are things that you can do better by
coding better in the first place so my
first tip was code better that saves you
from having to sort your selectors and
sort your properties just code properly
so that you're not putting crap into the
machine so it's gonna spit crap out
that's why it has cautions optimized
shorthands you can do safe optimizations
or all optimizations some shorthands may
be a little bit buggy so that's why you
can use safe optimizations compressed
colors if you're using the the color
three three three three three three you
could simply say pound three three three
and that's what this is going to do
compressing font weights that will help
you save some keystrokes or at least
some kilobytes in your CSS file
lowercase selectors this says it slower
casing the element names for HTML XHTML
but nobody cares what XHTML anymore so
don't worry about that
and any other elements here like remove
unnecessary back slashes or remove the
last semicolon little tip is in New York
Code you don't actually have to have a
semicolon on your last style so for
example here in this entire selector
final shadow typo right here this one
doesn't actually need a semicolon but I
always do it by default because I don't
want to get into the habit when I'm
writing vanilla CSS to forget to the
semicolon but in your production writing
site and you're compressing your code
you can have at it you can discard
invalid properties and add a timestamp
for when it was optimized up to you
process that CSS lets you know what went
what went on so it's saying if your
because I'm using css3 it's not they
doesn't know what's going on so what I
can do down here if I didn't want
invalid properties I can discard them
but I actually want them because I'm
using css3 so here is the output right
here this is one line so I'm gonna copy
that and show you what that looks like
so this is the the the original file and
this is what it would look like
compressed that's it
crazy it almost seems too short but
that's that's what it is so right here I
have about thirty nine lines of CSS
right here I've got technically one line
it's just one really long line so and
that's all the browser will load so
that's both validating and compressing
it's letting you know any sort of
messages here that you might need to
know so that is a neat little tool the
other thing which we just dated was
compress your CSS so when you're
developing you want that CSS to be
highly readable and easy to navigate
with your comments the spacing
organization your table of contents the
hacks and everything like that
instructions for developers or Co
developers but in like I said those
production ready sites like a live
client site or a live application
you'll need all that stuff because who's
gonna be reading that other developers
who click developer inspect tools and
read your CSS that's really it so in
those live sites you don't need all of
those all the organization all of the
comments and everything like that so
what you can do a little tip is have a
developer CSS file that is your let's
call it app dot CSS and then you have a
folder called production and then in
there you have another app dot CSS the
production app dot CSS is the file that
you would use to load that when you're
doing the live site but when you're
developing on the server you just simply
use your developer version now to show
you how you can kind of do that let's
let's do an example here so coat kit is
one of my favorite developer tools code
kit is a paid application there's a free
trial it's code kit app com I highly
suggest you support this guy it's just a
single dude I don't be single or not he
is just odd developer who builds an
awesome tool called code kit I truly
love it it's only like 30 bucks you can
actually pay what you want to anywhere
between you know 25 and 35 bucks or
whatever it is so I would recommend
supporting him code kit app com
basically this is like an all-in-one
compression output developer tool you
can you can do a ton with it but in a
very basic way you can optimize your CSS
and even compress images and do
everything like that and have it
automatically output into a folder that
you want so for example I have a folder
here called theme styles and then a
couple CSS files here I can actually say
output style compress I can choose how I
want it to be compressed and I can
change the path so let me say I'm gonna
create a new folder called production
like we just talked about and it's going
to say the main production on CSS you
can call whatever you want but I'm gonna
say this is going to take that file and
it's going to you know turn it into
something
I wanna hit process boom it's gonna do
that it compiled so in here now we have
a production file called theme in
production CSS let's check it out
so it's got all of the CSS that was in
the original theme CSS so all of this is
now compressed but I'm not over writing
this it's just got another file now the
magic of this is I can have it run
automatically when this file changes our
build so it's checking this file when it
changes
reowww put so as a little example if I
just delete everything and just say body
font size 12 pixels and leave it at that
and save it's going to re output it just
processed it and now that file is that
so it automatically happens so you don't
need to resave copy and paste take it
down do this that and all the other
things now I'm just going to change that
back because that was a very important
file so I'm gonna go back hit save it's
going to compile BAM everything is back
there we go
so I would highly suggest using code kit
for those production for getting and the
needing production ready files you can
optimize a ton of stuff but because this
is CSS we're just going to talk about
that the other thing that you can do is
preload your CSS and the browser so you
can improve the performance and the
loading time of your styles and your
websites by simply adding the following
code link preload href and whatever your
CSS is as style so you're basically
using the rel attribute to tell the
browser to preload this file as a style
and it will just check a little bit
earlier and load that style up so
there's less waiting time other thing
you could do is lighten up those
frameworks so bootstrap and other
similar frameworks are notoriously heavy
meaning that there are a lot of files
functions assets and code that you
simply do not need in the website maybe
you're just using the framework for like
the grid or button styles or base styles
if that's the case for you then when you
download the framework either remove
everything except what you plan on using
or just download specific files from the
framework that you need load it up into
your website your application and make
that will make the resources
quicker to load instead of using all of
bootstrap you can just use this part of
bootstrap that you actually need one
last thing that I want to leave you with
is learn a preprocessor language now I
do have a course on sass you could check
that out afterwards but you need to take
advantage of a CSS preprocessor like
sass or less and they'll not only save
you coding time but they'll give you
more flexibility when it comes to
styling and you can export highly
optimized images and create
production-ready sites and applications
but it's a really nice tool to know when
coding I'm here coding the vanilla css3
and while it's great I'm spending a lot
of time typing things that I don't need
to type if I'm using a preprocessor I
won't talk too much about that but I'd
highly suggest tech checking out my
course learn sass
so those are my tips for optimizing that
CSS code better validate compress
preload lighten up those frameworks
learn a preprocessor language and check
out tools like code kit CSS optimize and
I put a resource in the in the file and
a number 28 called shorthand properties
teaches you a little bit about using
short hands and a little bit of of how
to improve your CSS coding so thanks for
spending little 15 minutes or so
learning a little bit of theory and why
you should optimize your CSS see it
tomorrow and day number 29
[Music]